du côté gauche de l'échiquet politique
auunoir mi rebotte m sortant de l'autre
Jean-François Nicolas conseiller général
socialiste et candidat déclaré à hatin
le premier est toujours exclu du PS
suite à sa candidature dissidente lors
des dernières législatives le second
était candidat à l'investiture
socialiste mais les militants ont
largement désigné une proche de Rémi
reotte que le PS n'a pas retenu
finalement personne n'est officiellement
investi à hatin qui prend des aires de
terre de division au plan politique il y
a toujours eu une diversité c'est une
sorte de tradition une diversité de de
listes il y a toujours des listes à la
fois pluriel à droite et à gauche et
apparemment on s'orienterait de nouveau
vers cette vers cette option si j'ose
dire est-ce que vous pensez que vraiment
les les problèmes d'tin aujourd'hui sont
des problèmes de d'enjeux politiques ou
plutôt des enjeux de de gestion des
enjeux de euh de vitalité de la la ville
de de croissance de l'économie de
d'attractivité de notre territoire je
crois que c'est plutôt à ce niveau-là
que ça se pose et c'est pas en terme
politique lors de la présidentielle
Nicolas Sarkozi était arrivé d'une
courte tête devant François Hollande au
premier et au second tour à hatin la
division de la gauche pourrait dans ce
contexte faire les affaires de la droite
si elle-même n'était pas divisée Rémy
changgro est à la tête d'une liste UMP
udi Bertrand joli conteste ce choix et a
donc décidé de conduire sa propre liste
je n'ai pas d'adversaire moi c'est c'est
véritablement pour autant que nous
sommes tous engagés donc vous avez
décrit ptranjoli qui a refusé la main
que je lui ai tendu lorsque j'étais
choisi par rapport à lui et aujourd'hui
je sais pas si on peut le qualifier
comme adversaire de droite puisque il
est ni du MP ni du DI il est de son
propre parti pertranjoli moi je vais
vers lui on se dit bonjour Encore je
vais vers lui pour lui lui tendre la
main je lui tends la main encore et
toujours jusqu'à la dernière minute je
lui tendrai la main on doit s'unir on
peut s'unir et j'espère qu' qu'il
répondra à cet appel et qu'il le fera
l'unité elle existe je vous ai dit la
liste de droite UMP soutenue par l'UMP
l'UDI c'est celle que je porte donc ce
rassemblement je ne vois pas enfin une
5è candidature est déclarée celle de
Jacques perré patron indépendant d'une
radio locale lut ouvrière tenteré de
boucler une liste et le Front National
qui avait recueilli plus de 18 % des
voix au premier tour de la
présidentielle n'a pas encore fait part
de ses
intentions